[Music]
before animo became Mozambique's largest
opposition party it was a rebel group it
fought the governing for lemo party in a
15-year Civil War until a truce in 1992
free Lemos been declared the winner of
every election since ronaldo politicians
accused president felipe nooses
government of corruption and vote
rigging can you see here don't vote for
the first one that's the thief that we
talked about most people in this area
supported Ronaldo throughout the civil
war they say that means they were
deprived of all public services and
targeted with air raids bonamo and
Frelimo signed a peace deal in august is
the third there meant to be the final
agreement ending the conflict but not
everybody's happy with it Renato
leftenant general named Mariano Nyong'o
rejected the deal he's hiding in the
bush with an unknown number of fighters
we spoke to him one dear general when
people go to vote to be voting for war
we will fight the government that's not
a problem for us to avoid war the
government has to negotiate and
integrate all the Rijn armored forces
into the police in the army
therefore F is voting we are at war
younger doesn't accept venimos
presidential candidates for su fomo
mahdi as its true leader it was mama D
who signed the deal with president nu C
two months ago
Yabuki the future of Mozambique is
promising from now on the hostility
between members of the same family will
remain in history as Mozambicans prepare
to vote the Electoral Commission says
it's running a free and fair poll but
the opposition and rights groups say
there are serious problems the success
of the peace deal it depends on how this
election is going to be run but until
now we have seen enough problems to say
that this election will have problems of
credibility particularly when the
electoral institutions
they deny accreditation to independent
observers the elections credibility is
something that general Nyong'o and his
fighters had already rejected
Mozambicans are waiting to see if the
fragile peace will hold
Malcolm Webb al Jazeera boozy district
Mozambique